[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici les
titres
mercredi 28 avril un forum sur
l'apprentissage est organisée à la
maison de l'étudiant à vue en cours de
nombreux centres d'apprentis seront
présents nous ferons un point avec
sabine barre et développeuses de
l'apprentissage auprès de la région
ile-de-france et erwan le gall
conseiller communautaire délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle parole aussi à bruce la
bruce goldstein responsable
communication et marketing du vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
nous présentera le deuxième opus
hors-série la soirée électro se
déroulera les 4 et 5 juin
le forum de l'apprentissage à la maison
de l'étudiant c'est demain à guyancourt
l'apprentissage pour construire son
avenir ça se déroule de 10h à 16h une
large palette de métiers sont proposées
du ceap et au bac +5 pour en parler nous
recevons sur le plateau c'est d'une
barre et développeuses de
l'apprentissage auprès de la région ile
de france
bonsoir soins et antoine le gall
conseiller communautaire délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi et de l'insertion
professionnelle bonsoir bonsoir
alors pourquoi avoir décidé de mettre en
place cet événement alors j'avais ça
fait longtemps que je souhaitais
organiser un événement qui me permettent
de communiquer notamment auprès des
familles essayé de rassurer les parents
sur le fait que l'apprentissage c'est
une très très bonne solution de se
former et d'accéder à des diplômes qui
sont les mêmes que ceux qui finalement
de l'éducation nationale mais tout en
étant rémunéré en trouvant un sens à sa
formation en trouvant une motivation les
jeunes vont vraiment entre guillemets
s'éclater alors que il se serait
peut-être ennuyé à l'école derrière une
table
de façon classique et donc j'ai c'est
pour ça que j'ai contacté un peu la
communauté d'agglo donc notamment
monsieur le gala était très à l'écouté
dans ce domaine et m'a proposé de
m'accompagner pour organiser ce forum on
sait que monsieur le gall est vraiment
axé sur ce type de questions c'est une
demande dans l'agglomération il ya
encore il ya ce besoin pour les jeunes
en cite une demande oui mais vous l'avez
dit c'est aussi quelque chose qui
m'anime l'emploi je le dis à chaque fois
il ya un taux de chômage certes mais on
doit penser à l'avenir et l'avenir c'est
maintenant qu'ils se préparent c'est à
dire que c'est maintenant que les jeunes
doivent aller vers des filiales général
s'il le souhaite
très bien mais il ya d'autres filières
qui existent dont l'apprentissage et je
suis même temps tenir surtout
l'apprentissage pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux deux ces jeunes qui se
cherchent un petit peu et dernière on
sait le taux d'employabilité qu'il y ait
en france avec l'apprentissage
donc je crois qu'il faut pas se poser la
question il faut il y aller
alors il faut changer les mentalités
certain nombre de choses même bar et
lorsque j'ai croisé c'est une histoire
d'hommes et de femmes ces histoires de
forums moi on s'est découvert moi j'ai
confiance
on est prêt à le faire si on y va et de
conviction et bien sûr mais il faut y
aller faut après il va falloir voir ces
jeunes attirer d attirer et puis savoir
aussi ce qu'ils en retiennent c'est à
dire que je pensais surtout en ce moment
il faut être très à l'écouté de ce qui
se passe il faut humer un petit peu
aussi comment les jeunes réagissent
parce que les forums c'est bien mais ça
évolue
un énormément et malheureusement
malheureusement l'apprentissage est
tellement décriée et depuis 40 ans moi
j'entends que du mal quand il s'arrête
mais depuis que je fais de la politique
je n'y vois pas beaucoup de désavantages
alors je trouve ça assez
perturbant je pense qu'on devrait quand
même actionner marketé l'apprentissage
va faire du marketing comme vendu une
voiture
voilà vous vous dites c'est souvent
c'est décrié on connaît pas très bien
l'apprentissage et puis en discutant un
petit peu avant l'émission
vous m'avez dit que c'est souvent les
bacs plus de risques au bac +5 et qui
use de l'apprentissage pourquoi pas
laisser happer il ya vraiment une
mauvaise vision parents veulent pas
emmener leurs enfants donc 60% des
jeunes à cette année des apprentis sont
effectivement de niveau bac +2 à
supérieur et c'est vrai que on a le
problème oui effectivement des parents
qui font tout pour amener le jeune
jusqu'à un bac général en se disant
qu'après il aura peut-être plus de
possibilités ce qui est vrai mais on
voit bien sur le terrain des jeunes qui
s'ennuient à l'école qui ne qui végète
en gros et qui ne prennent plus leur
destin romain parce qu'ils s'ennuient et
qui sont plus motivés et qui pourrait
vraiment trouver leur compte dans
l'apprentissage et malheureusement c'est
vrai que l'éducation nationale m'a
ouvert les portes au niveau de
l'académie mais sur le terrain encore et
est encore réticentes on a des objectifs
de jeunes a amené vers le bac général et
on a beaucoup de mal notamment dans les
niveaux c'est ap pourtant dans lesquels
on a beaucoup de travail c'est à dire
que l'année dernière par exemple en
avait environ 500 employeurs pour la
chambre de métiers de versailles qui
n'avaient pas d'apprentis à mettre en
face donc dans tous les domaines de la
cuisine boulangerie coiffure voilà il y
avait plein de métiers où on n'a pas de
jeunes à mettre en face et cdn
il faut bien garder en mémoire que ces
jeunes quand ils vont commencer par un c
ap ils vont pouvoir après continuer
c'est à dire qu'il ya tout un parcours
qui est possible en apprentissage et ils
seront pas planter avec leur crp au
contraire ils vont pouvoir rebondir et
continue et c'est ce qui se passe très
souvent parce que les jeunes une fois
qu'ils sont partis dans l'apprentissage
qui sont vraiment maîtres de leur destin
ctions motivé repartis ils vont choisir
de continuer bien souvent décidé de
faire un autre diplôme est de continuer
par infraction
mais comment on l'est on les attire en
fait tous ces jeunes du ca paix jusqu'au
bac
on va dire des fois ils connaissent pas
très bien ses métiers ses images
et par des parents aux coiffeurs alors
qu' il ya une véritable carrière à
fernand oui mais mbaye va très bien
expliqué c'est à dire que à un moment il
n'ya pas il va falloir qu en france
arrêtés des doubles et triples discours
je n'ai pas de langue de bois vous le
savez très bien mais l'éducation
nationale un moyen pour arrêter dire
qu'on ne peut pas tenir un discours à
l'extérieur pour vendre l'apprentissage
et puis rester toujours en inclusion
permanente et dire aux parents l'écouté
n'en faudrait quand même bien continuer
en effet rien les filières générales oui
donc leur double discours qui aussi et
frais les chefs d'entreprises parce qu
un moyen aussi s'y perdre il n'y a pas
que ça parce que les normes etc
aussi il ya des freins qui font que
c'est ça n'aide pas le chef d'entreprise
mais je suis assez d'accord moi qui vous
voit beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise ils
ne sont pas fermés à prendre des
apprentis
il ya 72 centres de formation aussi sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
je vais en visité un certain nombre
depuis depuis plus d'un an
pareil on voit qui est une vraie
dynamique on voit qu'il se passe quelque
chose et les jeunes malheureusement vous
venez de le dire ils ne sont pas
forcément au courant
une fois qu'ils le sont et qu'ils ont
pris un chemin différent il le regrette
il le regrette parce qu'il ya aussi une
source financière derrière savez c'est
qu'ils ont un petit peu de pécule et
puis ça permet aussi de participer à un
peu de loisirs tout en ayant aussi ce
côté très structuré d'adulte ce sont des
jeunes adultes mais j'ai de l'argent
j'apprends un travail j'apprends aussi
la théorie à l'école que j'applique
après dans un milieu professionnel je
décode aussi
l'entreprise parce qu'une entreprise a
des codes et puis je m'insère aussi dans
un milieu d'adultes
voilà donc que la vieille a que des
bonnes choses dans l'apprentissage mais
il faut que ce soit rayon enfin on
l'oublié de parler de la coiffure mais
pour ouvrir un salon de coiffure il faut
un bp de coiffure ouais voilà avec un c
ap vous ne l'avez pas ont pourtant un
coiffeuse ou un coiffeur en alternance a
fait un apprentissage peut grandir et
puis même les faire de grandes choses et
puis vous regardez les grands les
grandes entreprises françaises de
certains groupes 1 vous savez ils ont
démarré par apprentissage
il faut prendre aussi en exemple au 6e
jour de deux personnes mais c'est vrai
que c'est important je pense que chaque
jeune sage qu'il a le choix dans la
poursuite de ses études
après c'est vrai que ça ne correspond
pas tous les profits non il ya des
jeunes qui vont s'y sentir déstabiliser
parce que l'apprentissage c'est pas
justement une voie de garage ou où on va
mettre les nuls entre guillemets parce
qu'au contraire c'est plutôt plus
beaucoup plus difficile c'est plus
exigeant un rythme plus soutenu faut
vraiment être proactif dynamique on peut
pas faire ça comme ça et c'est vrai que
c'est important de savoir qu'on a le
choix mais après de voir si ça
correspond à son profil ou pas mais je
pense qu'une fois qu'on est parti dans
l'apprentissage
il ya peu de gens enfin j'ai rarement
croisé quelqu'un qui m'a dit non je
regrette ce choix quoi c est bien merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau ne partez pas
vous partez trop rapidement le forum de
l'apprentissage à la maison de
l'étudiant
c'est demain à gurs en cours de 10h à
16h et si vous recherchez vous voulez
connaître un petit peu la suite des
aventures pour vous et bien allez-y
c'est important un événement culturel
pour conclure ce set 8 les invités
connaissez vous la nuit de d'électro
hors série alors non mais aussi 7 6
litres au dance et ça c'est l'électro
dance jusqu'à présent tu es bien la
soirée va investir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
après la gare saint lazare en septembre
dix artistes dont anne et à octave one
ou paranoid
je ne connais pas moi même serons
présents de pendant quinze heures de
concert environ 5000 personnes sont
attendues donc c'est un grand concert
écoutez booth golstein chargé de
communication au vélodrome les 4 et 5
juin prochain c'est le hors série
d'offres déjà qu'est ce que c'est alors
le hors série c'est l'un des plus fameux
festival électro sur la place parisienne
à la base et donc ils ont testé et oser
venir réaliser l'expérience opéra
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
dix artistes presque 15 heures de
concert c'est ça
comment ça va se dérouler alors bref
vous l'avez dit en se pendant 15 heures
avec une série de têtes d'affiché
successives on errant sur un modèle
classique en termes de festival on va
accueillir un peu plus de 4000 personnes
voire 5000 à l'intérieur du vélodrome
national sur le modèle
d autres festivals qui se réalise à
l'international ce que c'est aussi un
festival a raison ce international donc
donc voilà on rend très content de
réaliser l'expérience ici 50 en une dans
le style qu'est ce que c'est c'est de la
house sait quel genre de scène alors
c'est de l'électro c'est un concrètement
de l'électro avec comme je l'aï dit à
l'instant et les têtes d'affiché les
plus célèbres au niveau national mais
aussi international quelques noms
peut-être voilà de mémoire difficile ça
c'est pas pas ma spécialité mais les
organisateurs on va vous voulez des
livres et c'est vraiment laid les plus
célèbres dans le milieu électro
ça va se passer ou dans l'air centrale
ça va parce que circuler dans l'examen
ouais exclusivement à l'intérieur donc
on a pris soin de respecter le cahier
des charges qui nous a été imposée par
la mairie de montigny donc exclusivement
à l'intérieur du vélodrome nationale et
non pas intérieur extérieur
donc oui effectivement on aura une scène
centrale sur l'art centrale est ici
juste ici derrière moi avec un flux de
personnes qui circulera évidemment au
centre de l'aréna mais également en
tribune une petite précision dans les
annonces
interdit aux mineurs sa masse et le sait
la loi qui veut ça aussi on va avoir de
la vente de certaines boissons
alcoolisées
et puis par mesure de sécurité également
c'est important de respecter le cahier
des charges qui se fait habituellement
est traditionnellement ce type de
manifestation donc effectivement
interdit aux mineurs ce hors série ce
sera la deuxième édition la première a
eu lieu le 3 septembre
ces lieux sont pas sûrs d'être dans une
gare parisienne avec 5000 personnes vous
attendez la même influence
exactement c'est le même objectif de
jauge donc c'était la gare saint lazare
et le modèle de la série c'est justement
de d'accomplir cet événement dans des
lieux insolites donc le 20e roman fait
partie évidemment effectivement objectif
cinquième personne une belle continuité
après le succès du match de handball
féminin c'est le vélodrome continue à se
diversifier
l'euro poursuit sa quête de
diversification effectivement on a aussi
pour mission de développer le volet
culturel de l'enceinte
donc on est en plein dedans festival
électro culture on sort sur le succès du
handball effectivement mais pas que
puisque là c'est plus du sport mais de
la culture
il y aura beaucoup de danse donc petit
côté sport aussi effectivement mais oui
on est on est vraiment dans notre coeur
de métier à savoir accueillir des
événements multimodaux c'est dans un peu
plus d'un mois les places sont déjà en
vente
comment ça se passe tout à fait on a
ouvert la billetterie à environ un mois
même trois semaines peut-être on a vendu
1000 places en 72 heures donc ça suit
son cours on sera très certainement
complet avant avant l'échéance merci
merci à vous c'est la fin de ce set 8
les invités merci de nous avoir suivis
et surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]